Zimbabwe's president-elect is in a very
good mood
Alex Crawford from Sky News he's giving
his first interview since claiming
victory to Sky News the British
Chancellor time we'll just take a few
minutes to set up this would have been
inconceivable a year ago the British
were considered the old enemy and many
journalists including those from Sky
were unable to work do you feel you want
it freely and fairly it was a free fair
transparent process from the period of
campaigning to the period of the actual
voting everybody has declared the
process free peaceful and transparent
well not every the main opposition party
the MDC and it's much younger leader is
threatening a legal challenge claiming
even before the votes were in that the
result was rigged that's getting short
shrift this single one is the one which
you spoke about inciting violence even
during the time of campaigning although
during that time no violence okayed that
is their identity their identity is that
of Alice there were some ugly scenes the
president-elect says much of it was
hooliganism
but many it seemed like the old Zimbabwe
with live shots fired and wanton
beatings by the Army in that
at least six people were killed this
woman died after being shot in the back
the president-elect insists he'll hunt
down and punish the perpetrators is
there any way that you consider a
government of national unity
given the the split in the vote in 1964
Harold Wilson of Britain they do one
seat between the conservative by one
seat and they formed the government they
ruled England and I have to tell
majority and they are talking about me
have bad an invite to this majority to
think a government of national unity
know that is a better idea but it
doesn't show that there's any need I am
saying the politics should now take the
back seat because the elections are
behind us we should now put our
shoulders to the wheel for purposes of
modernizing our economy growing our
economy together those who are fighting
against me
those who voted for me we say Zimbabwe
is ours together let's move on the best
argument the best vision the best ideas
are taken are the day you will be once
you're inaugurated you will be the first
president that's bound by two five-year
terms yes
are you willing to give a guarantee to
the people of Zimbabwe that you will
stick to that perfectly and I always
said that I will I will obey the
Constitution to the letter the spirit of
the question to the letter I will remain
if I'm elected for second Tim I will do
my second Tim but they're giving to Bob
Union at the Bob wheeze longtime
dictator Robert Mugabe was toppled last
November when the army intervened he was
replaced by his former Protege humid avi
had sacked the week before
and your relationship with him now until
recently when he said he did not want to
vote for me I didn't think you would
reach that stage of what it was there's
nothing wrong I have done to him but he
is this democratic right to choose us to
whom he votes for I have no problem with
President Mugabe Petrelli whenever
fornum and we discussed with this no
enemy tree there is no rancor between me
and him the president-elect was in the
Mugabe government which presided over
Landry distributions which prompted
Western sanctions led by Britain it led
to an economic crisis a collapse in the
currency and soaring unemployment
I don't regret than proof does not
regret and the people whose bubble do
not regret despite the suffering that
came on our people as a result of those
sanctions we do not regret to apply to
Island again
do you still have resentment no
fortunately stam Britain is a woman
leader things are better because in 1979
when with my profession
she stopped our war and products the
table and what our independence this
time with Prime Minister treason act
resume again upon my in aggression she
sent an F way to meet me so they can be
arranged
well engaged and it's so beautiful and
so nice so I would wish that the British
people continue led to remain Prime
Minister's your nickname is the
crocodile right which sounds scary I
mean they're not many friendly
crocodiles do you feel you've got a
reputation that is feared no no no I'm
his soft his warmth but your opponents I
imagine should should fear me
no no I'm very friendly to them good
asking or one of them they will tell you
that there is a very humble person and
they're very friendly and you feel
you're fair extremely fair extremely
fair you can't ask them and what kind of
leader do you hope to be in the future
the people's leader and listener a
listening leader a humble leader a
separate leader
thank you thank you Alex Crawford Sky
News Harare